MEANWHILE, HERE COMES KYROU
BETWEEN HIS OWN LEGS.. IN THE S
TOREY KRUG.
AGGRESSIVE
CHICAGO TIES IT UP.
PUCK SPINNING ON THE WALL.
I DON'T THINK HE HANDLES AT THE
WAY HE WANTED TO. S OFFSIDE.
JONES.
KANE WANTED.
SHOT.
JU
>> Brian: NO GOAL IN
SHOT TOWARDS BINNINGTON.THE CRO
THAT
THE ST. LOUIS DEFENDER, SHEN,
AFTER SLOWLY
INTO THE NETTING.
SHOT THROUGH TRAFFIFI
EASILY CAUGHT BYFOR NOW, HE ISIS
SCORE OF THE
TIPS IT IN FOR GOOD MEASURE.
SAVED.ME UP WITH THAT SAVE
THERE.
CAN'T.
GOES BACK TO 88.
IN FRONT.
DEFLECTS T T
A LOT OF ACTION IN FRONT OF SAY
BINNINGTON, REBOUND.
GREAT DEFENSIVE PLAY
KERA GOT THE FIRS
PLAYED WITH THE PANTHERS.
FINISHED WITH TORONTO.
DEFLECTS THE SHOT FROM THE
POINT.
AND THE CHICAGO BLACKHAWKS HAVE
TI
BEAUTIFUL.
YOU CAN SEE BINNINGTON WAS
SLIDING TO HIS TIME IS HERE IN
>> John: THREE ON THREE